[Applause]
breaking overnight protesters clash with
police in downtown Las Vegas you're
looking at video of that happening some
protesters threw bottle water bottles
rather at police officers and deploy
tear gas to disperse the crowd those
protests of course were against the
death of George Floyd at the hands of
Minnesota police they've been ongoing
now for several days across our country
thank you for being with us this morning
I'm Alex Backus and for Bianca we're now
seeing the aftermath of those protests
and several businesses are damaged this
morning our Joe Moller is live now
downtown with the very latest good
morning Joe
good morning Alex yeah that protests now
over and we're getting a look at what
happened last night to some of the
destruction this morning we're seeing
graffiti all over buildings and some
broken windows we're the easy pawn at
Carson Avenue in Las Vegas Boulevard you
can see this window here which is
smashed in and if we take a short walk
right over here the front doors to this
business here are broken as well when
some of our crews were here last night
and saw some items being taken from this
now let's go ahead and pull in the video
from last night thousands flooded
downtown streets as it got later in the
night he got even more chaotic a metro
police car was even lit on fire metro
police officers in tactical gear formed
a line on the streets going face-to-face
with protesters some protesters started
throwing water bottles our crews saw
officers put on their face masks and
then throw what seemed to be teargas or
pepper spray into the ground people
immediately started running in all
directions we're here listening to
families that have been impacted by mass
incarceration and by police killing
folks they're not letting us they're not
letting them speak
all right ask for this morning we took a
look around taking a look at what was
left behind down Fremont I counted at
least four different shops with busted
windows several businesses were covered
in graffiti including the El Cortez now
back out of here live we didn't shoot
much of that graffiti because a lot of
it is profanity you can see it on
windows you can see it on euros downtown
so it's a lot of it you can't just show
because there's a lot of profanity on
those signs but as far as arrests they
have not released how many arrests were
made last night police estimate that
there was between 1500 and 2000
protesters we live in downtown Las Vegas
jumble 8 news now so what we have you
really quickly you know businesses a lot
of them were forced to close last night
because of these protests and
unfortunately they're gonna go back
today and see damage are you seeing
anyone out there yet that's assessing
the damage yeah well last night we saw a
number of post on social media
businesses closing due to this protest
and a lot of them boarded up windows but
we were seeing some one business owner
actually talked to he didn't want to go
on camera he explained he just wanted to
get his business cleaned up there was
pots that were broken outside with
flowers in it there was some chairs
thrown some different items in the
streets so as you can imagine they're
just trying to get get back to normal
for their businesses but a lot of owners
not down here just yet so a lot of them
will see the graffiti that is there on a
Fremont this morning but I'm sure
throughout the day a lot of people will
be helping out with a cleaner that's too
bad to see all right Joe thanks for that
reporting